RONALD SMITH: We're starting a new subject
and I wanted to just remind
you what we've done, so you
see how this fits into the
larger picture.
We spent quite a few weeks
looking at physical processes
in the atmosphere, like why do
winds blow, the geostrophic
law, hydrostatic law,
thermodynamics of lifting air,
how clouds form, how rain forms,
how radiation causes
the layering in the
atmosphere.
So that was an important
section.
Now we're moving into some
other sections that are a
little more descriptive.
We'll still be doing some
quantitative work as we move
through the course, but for
the moment, we're kind of
putting some of these
pieces together
to see the big picture.
So we looked at the general
circulation of the atmosphere.
And then last week we
looked at storms,
various storm types.
Now we're going to put those two
things together and try to
look at the distribution of
climate around the globe.
And I'm going to do
this in part--
I'm going to start out very
briefly ignoring the seasons.
But we can't get very far with
describing climate without
understanding the seasons, how
the seasons work in various
places, because that's
such an important
part of climate also.
So what's up here says that we
can describe climate pretty
well if we know the monthly
values of temperature and
precipitation.
That would be 24 numbers.
With 24 numbers, what are
the average precip
values for each month?
What are the average
temperature
values for each month?
That's pretty much a full
description of climate.
The way you would normally do
that is to collect data for 10
or 20 or 30 years, and then
you'd average together all the
Januarys to get the average
January, all the Februarys to
get the average February.
And you'd plot that up as the
average seasonal cycle.
And that's typically the
definition of climate.
Now, storms come into that
because very often, storms are
controlling the precipitation.
But you might want to include
some other aspects of
climatology not mentioned
here.
For example, if an area is prone
to hurricanes, probably
a description of climate should
include that as a
little separate item, because
it's important for the people
that live there and the
farmers and the
fishermen and so on.
So the definition of climate
is not quite cut and dried,
but I would say that for the
most part, you need those 24
numbers in order to describe the
climate of any particular
place on the Earth.
The factors that control climate
are primarily these.
Latitude, because of the way
that the general circulation
tends to give a latitudinal
structure to climate--
the Hadley cells, the belts of
storms, the belts of deserts.
So as you go from latitude to
latitude, you're kind of
moving through these
different zones.
So latitude's very important,
but it's not everything.
Mountains play a very big
role, something called
continentality--
which I'll describe
in a minute--
and ocean currents also play
a role in determining what
climate it is.
And I'll be going through
these today.
So just to remind you about
the general circulation,
you've got the symmetry about
the equator, with a Hadley
cell rising near the equator
sending air poleward in both
hemispheres, descending near
the tropics of Cancer and
Capricorn, and then the trade
winds under the influence of
the Coriolis force--
these winds don't move directly
back towards the equator.
Instead they get deflected to
the right and to the left and
end up being the northeast and
the southeast trade winds.
And then you've got the
belts of storms,
the belts of deserts.
And so if this were the full--
if you took away the
continents--
if you either had a uniform
ocean-covered planet or a
uniform land-covered planet,
then you could probably pretty
much end with the latitudinal
control.
That'd be really the
dominant factor.
But in fact, you've got mountain
belts, you've got
continents, you've got oceans,
you've got ocean currents, all
of which give some east-west
variations in climate.
So it's not just latitude
control, as this diagram would
have you think, but it also
depends where you are because
of the mountains,
the continents,
and the ocean currents.
Stop me if you have any
questions here.
So when you look at an
annual precip map--
this is for land only.
So this is traditional data
collected from rain gauges,
summed up over many years,
and summed up over all
the seasons as well.
So this is annual
precipitation.
You do see the latitudinal
control from the general
circulation.
You see a belt of rainforest
near the equator, expressed in
South America, in Africa, and
in the continent-- in the
so-called maritime continent
off of southeast Asia.
You see the belt of deserts in
both hemispheres about here,
but it's best expressed
in the Sahara desert
and the Arabian peninsula.
Then it tends to slide northward
a little bit because
of the mountains here.
And we see it expressed a
little bit in the desert
southwest, but not so much
in Florida, for example.
And then the mirror image of
that coming down here--
you see the belt of deserts
especially on the west coast
of South America, the west coast
of Africa, and most of
the interior of Australia.
Now the high latitudes appear
as areas with very small
precipitation.
I hesitate to call them deserts,
however, because
remember, because they're
cold, the evaporation
rate is very slow.
And so what little precipitation
you get could
cause a very moist
climate there.
So precipitation is not
the only factor.
Evaporation plays an equally
important role in determining
the climate of these
various regions.
So as you've seen, then, you
can see this latitudinal
control, but it's also
quite broken up
by these other factors--
the mountains, the continents,
and the ocean currents.
Probably one of the best
examples of that is in South
America, where you've got a wet
west coast and a dry east
coast in these mid-latitudes.
Well, that's because this is
the belt of westerlies.
The winds are coming
like this.
They have to climb over
the mountains there.
As the air rises, it cools
adiabatically, and you get
rain on the west coast. But then
the air descends and you
get dry conditions on
the east coast.
You go up here--
it's just reversed.
The dry is on the west coast,
the wet is in the interior,
but this is the belt
of easterlies.
So you get this orographic
effect, this mountain effect,
kind of reversed.
You find it elsewhere, but
nowhere quite as nicely
expressed as in the Andes and
the southern Andes there.
So that's a good example of
where mountains are screwing
up that simple latitudinal
distribution of climate.
When you include the oceans--
and now this comes not from
traditional land-based weather
stations, of course.
This is a satellite product.
We've had satellites in orbit
that can detect precipitating
clouds for a decade or more,
and so we can begin to put
together a full global picture
of precipitation.
You still see the maxima over
the continents, just where we
had them in the other pictures--
the belt of
rainforest is here and here.
But you also see what's going
on over the oceans.
And rather dramatically, you
find these east-west elongated
structures, especially
in the North Pacific.
And remember, the equator
is right here.
And that is an expression of the
inter-tropical convergence
zone, where the two trade
winds are converging.
Notice it's not at
the equator.
It's north of the equator.
In the Western Pacific, you
have a double structure,
indicating that the
inter-tropical convergence
zone spends a few months a year
here and a few months a
year there.
So it tends to move back and
forth a little bit in the in
the western tropical Pacific.
Generally very dry conditions
where you see the purples, and
wetter conditions where you see
the warmer colors there.
Questions on this?
Again, this is annual average,
so the seasons don't show up
in this yet.
I'm going to get to the seasons
in a couple of moments.
When you take a diagram like
this and average it east to
west, it's called
a zonal average.
A zonally averaged precipitation
would be, at
each latitude, just average
around the globe to get the
total precipitation.
And that gives you a
diagram like this.
Now, this is broken up by
season, or by month of the
year rather, but they're not
so terribly different.
Basically, it's a three-humped
profile.
Three peaks.
The biggest one is somewhere
around the equator, although
you see it moves around a
little bit with month.
And that's the inter-tropical
convergence zone.
Winds converging at
low altitudes.
The air goes up, deep clouds,
heavy precipitation.
Then you get the belt
of deserts.
So even though you have all
these interferences due to
mountains and ocean currents
and continents and so on,
still you see that three-banded
structure come
through that's based on the
general circulation.
The ITCZ, the two belts of
deserts where air is
descending in the
Hadley cells.
And then these are the belts of
mid-latitude storms. This
is up in the westerlies, where
you're getting all these comma
clouds and cold fronts and warm
fronts moving west to
east, bringing you
precipitation.
So three nice peaks, a
certain symmetry--
that's what the general
circulation is doing.
Questions here?
OK.
We can zoom in to a particular
continent, like North America
or our own country.
Here is the annual average
precipitation.
The values are given
here in inches.
The dry values are the deep
reds and the highest
precipitations are the
blues and the grays.
And the highest precipitation
in our country generally
occurs in the west coast,
especially the Pacific
Northwest, where you get a lot
of moist air masses and
frontal storms moving in off
the Pacific Ocean, hitting
these mountains.
And so you get the combination
of cyclonic frontal storms
which are already precipitating,
then the air
has to run up over the
mountains, and you get the
extra precip there.
Most of that water is removed
that moves on from the Pacific
Ocean by the mountain ranges of
the west coast, leaving the
interior rather dry.
That's kind of a rain
shadow effect.
And a fundamental question would
be, OK, if I've rained
all the water out, or for
whatever reason I'm not
getting the precipitation
downstream of the coastal
mountains, how far does that
effect extend eastward?
And you see it here.
By the time you get west of--
into Colorado--
and then eastward of that you're
gradually starting to
pick up your precipitation
again.
But that's because
you now have got
some new water sources.
You've got moist air moving up
in this region off the Gulf of
Mexico, and along the east
coast, you've got some, even
though you're in the belt of
westerlies, you occasionally
have easterly flow that can
bring moist air in off the
Atlantic Ocean.
So eventually this rain shadow
reduces in its effect when you
pick up some other water
vapor sources.
Question?
STUDENT: In about the
middle of the
country, it has that line--
why is it so-- instead of being
longer, why is it so
abrupt a change?
PROFESSOR: You're speaking
about this
gradient through here?
Well, basically, remember
you're also descending.
You're coming down into lower
altitudes as you come across
the Great Plains.
And that, again, helps
this moisture to
get up in that region.
But basically this is just
the ending of the--
the further you get east, the
more you have the influence of
that new water vapor source.
I'd say that's the primary
thing controlling that
gradient region.
So just to zoom in on
California, then--
and again, the blue colors are
high precipitation and the
reds are low.
So there's a coastal mountain
range that has precip.
Then the central valley, which
is quite dry, and then the
Sierra Nevada range which
lifts the air again.
So this is a nice example of
orographic precipitation.
Orographic precipitation is
defined as precipitation
caused by the lifting of
air by a mountain.
And the thermodynamics
of it you are already
quite familiar with.
You lift the air.
It's moving to lower pressure
because pressure decreases as
you go up in the atmosphere.
The air expands, cools
adiabatically--
you've heard this story
over and over now.
It drops the saturation
vapor pressure.
The relative humidity finally
exceeds 100%.
The excess water vapor condenses
and, under the right
conditions, you can get
precipitation coming out of
those clouds.
So orographic precipitation
is really a big control.
And the rivers that provide
water to the people and the
agriculture in California
basically get their water from
the mountains.
So the water that falls in the
mountains by this process
pretty much gives California
the water it needs for
agriculture and for
human consumption.
It's a pretty dry state
except for the
influence of the mountains.
Oregon is a similar thing.
Look at the contrast between the
eastern and western part
of the state.
Precipitation in the west can
be 140 to 160 inches.
That would be this much water.
In the eastern part of the
state where that air has
climbed over the mountain range
and now it descends
again, having lost most of its
water, the precipitation is
less than this amount.
So that's a big contrast. And
if you drive across there,
boy, you see it immediately
in the vegetation.
A kind of rainforest here on
the west coast of Oregon.
You begin to see ponderosa pine,
then they get sparser
and sparser.
And by the time you get to
eastern Oregon, there's mostly
grasses and just a scattered
pine tree or so.
Alaska is another good
example of this.
There's a coastal
mountain range.
Here's precipitation.
The purples are the
high precip.
And you get that moist air
coming off the Pacific Ocean,
giving you heavy rainfalls
in the mountains.
And then north of that
and east of that, the
precipitation dies out
quite quickly.
In the north, you're getting
very low precipitation,
because as I mentioned, the air
that gets to those very
high polar latitudes is cold.
If it's cold, it means that it's
gone through a cooling
process as it moved from
low latitudes.
And the cooling has probably
already removed most of its
water vapor.
So cold air, remember, can't
hold very much water vapor.
And therefore you can't wring
out very much rain from cold
air, because it doesn't have
very much water to begin with.
So finding these seemingly
desert-like precipitations--
200 millimeters, 20
centimeters--
is a result of the air being too
cold to provide much water
vapor to that region.
Arizona is complicated because
it's got mountains in certain
areas and low-lying areas, but
this is the mountainous area,
and pretty much the high
precipitation is controlled by
the mountains.
But generally, it's a
pretty dry state.
Notice the highest precipitation
here.
What's that say?
Yeah, the highest precipitation
would be 32
inches, about this much, up
in the highest mountains.
I wanted to just mention
this briefly.
Occasionally I like to give you
some idea of what we do in
our department.
I've had an interest in
orographic precipitation for a
number of years, and I noticed
a few years ago that there'd
been a lot of studies of
it in mid-latitudes
but none in the tropics.
So my group put together a field
experiment last May.
I took a leave from Yale
University last April and May
to do a project down on the
island of Dominica in the
eastern Caribbean, where we
were looking at orographic
precipitation in a tropical
location where you have the
steady trade winds.
This is a precipitation map for
the island of Dominica.
Upstream over the ocean you get
maybe two millimeters per
day on average.
But yet, over the high
mountains, you get 12 to 14
millimeters per day.
That's about that much
rain each day, on
average, over the year.
And then to the west, almost
absolutely dry.
So a very strong example of
orographic precipitation.
And we went down there for five
weeks and flew research
aircraft back and forth over the
island through the clouds,
trying to understand the details
of how the clouds are
formed, how the precipitation
is formed, and how this rain
shadow in the lee comes to be.
I don't have time to tell you
about the results of that.
But that's the kind of research
that one can do to
understand in more detail many
of these features that I'm
just glossing over and saying,
well, look, here's an
interesting factor, here's an
interesting process, here's an
interesting part of the Earth.
They've all got their own
physics, only a small fraction
of which is really understood.
So one can chip away at this and
try to understand more and
more of the details of how
the atmosphere works.
Questions here?
So continentality.
What is that?
Well, it primarily has to do
with the fact that oceans
store heat very effectively,
whereas land surfaces do not.
So it's easy to change the
temperature on land.
You don't have to provide very
much heat or remove very much
heat to warm up or cool down
a land surface, because
remember, all you're doing
is heating the first few
centimeters of the soil.
And that's not very much
heat capacity.
So you put in a little bit of
heat, the temperature rises.
You take out some heat,
the temperature drops.
You try to do that over
the ocean and two
things get in the way.
First of all, water has a
very high heat capacity.
That is to say, per kilogram,
it's got a large ability to
store heat.
Second of all, water is a
liquid, which means it's not
just the first few centimeters
you have got to cool
down or heat up.
It's probably the first several
hundred meters,
because that water is constantly
being stirred.
So you can't just heat or cool
the top few centimeters.
You've got to heat or cool the
top few hundred meters of the
ocean, which is an enormous
heat capacity.
So generally temperatures don't
change very much over
the ocean, either between
day and night--
a typical temperature difference
between day and
night over the ocean is about
a half a degree Celsius,
whereas on land it could be 5,
10, even in some places 15
degrees Celsius or higher.
And between the seasons, between
the warm season and
the cold season, you've got
a similar difference.
In the ocean you might only be
able to have a three or four
degree temperature difference.
Over land, you might have 15,
20, 30, 40 degrees Celsius
difference between winter
and summer.
So continentality is this
contrast in the heat storage
capability of land
versus ocean.
So here is a plot of the annual
range of temperature.
It's the typical maximum
temperature versus the minimum
temperature.
First of all, you don't see much
of a range in the tropics
anyway, over land or sea,
because there's not that much
difference in how the
sun hits the tropics
between winter and summer.
I'll say more about
that later.
So let's shift our attention
more to mid-latitudes,
especially to the northern
latitudes where you have a
couple of very large
continents and
then oceans in between.
Look, the oceans barely change
their temperature between
winter and summer, but the
continents change their
temperature by a great deal.
For example, up in the northern
part of eastern
Eurasia, you could have an
annual range of 55--
I think that's in Celsius--
of 55 degrees between
winter and summer.
That's an enormous temperature
difference.
That's sweltering in the summer
and so cold it's hard
to describe how cold it
is in the wintertime.
So in the middle of continents,
you get this
enormous temperature range.
Continentality.
Any questions on that?
It's a big player in climate,
as you can imagine.
You see it in the southern
hemisphere too, but not so
much, because by the time you
get to midlatitudes--
you know, the big difference
between northern and southern
hemisphere in this regard is
that the northern hemisphere
is the hemisphere
of continents.
The southern hemisphere is more
the hemisphere of oceans.
The percent land mass is much
greater in the northern
hemisphere that it is in the
southern hemisphere,
especially if you're excluding
the equatorial region.
So by the time you get down to
the mid-latitudes, you really
only have Australia, New
Zealand, a little bit of
Africa, and the tip
of South America.
Whereas in the same latitude
belt in the northern
hemisphere, you have
massive continents.
So there's this asymmetry
between the northern and
southern part of our planet,
climate-wise, because of the
way continentality works
differently in the two
hemispheres.
You notice, if you did a zonal
average of this quantity,
you'd find a much bigger annual
range in the northern
hemisphere than in the
southern hemisphere.
Well, that has nothing
to do with how the
sun hits the Earth.
Over a year that's pretty much
symmetric between the northern
and southern hemispheres.
But it has everything to do
with the fact that there's
more continents in the northern
hemisphere than there
are in the southern
hemisphere.
Here it is over the United
States, the annual range of
temperature.
It's largest in this interior
region of the west, where it's
dry and high.
If you have higher elevation,
you tend to have a larger
annual range, because there's
less air above you.
You can cool down
more at night.
And it's drier.
There are fewer clouds,
more sunlight.
It can heat up more
during the day.
So you see the continentality
here expressed in a little bit
of a confusing way.
Because you'd say, well, that
point's just as much in the
middle of the continent
as that is.
Yeah, but there are other
things having to do with
elevation, clouds, that will
cause some change in that
annual range, even within
the same continent.
Alaska has a very small annual
range near the ocean.
Of course that's because it's
close to the ocean, which is
buffering the temperature.
And then up in the interior,
especially in high latitudes
where there's a great deal of
difference between summer and
winter insolation--
solar radiation--
you get a very big annual
range in temperature.
And finally, I'll mention
ocean currents.
I've shown this diagram
before.
But generally in each of the
ocean basins, you have a
gyre-- wind-driven gyre.
But it carries, generally, cold
water near the equator--
sorry, cold water towards the
equator and warm water away
from the equator, or we
could say, poleward.
So if you lived on this side,
along this coast, you'd have a
cold current off of your beach,
whereas here, you'd
have a warm current off of it.
So for example, if you're a
Californian, you've got the
cold California current coming
down along the coast. That's
why it's always exciting when
you go swimming in southern
California.
Beautiful nice warm climate,
beautiful beaches, but be
prepared for a shock when you
jump in the water, because the
water's always cold there,
because you've got the
California current.
Whereas when I go vacationing
down on Cape Hatteras, for
example, in the summertime, you
can walk in the water and
it's very, very pleasant and
warm, because that is warm
water being brought northwards
in the Gulf Stream.
So that's a real difference.
And notice that's going to work
oppositely, typically, on
the two sides of a continent.
You're going to have cold water
or warm water, depending
where you fit into that
current scheme.
Yeah?
STUDENT: Why is the cold
water always on the
left side of the continent?
PROFESSOR: The question
is, why is the cold
water always over here?
Well, these gyres always go--
notice in the southern
hemisphere, they're always
going counterclockwise.
In the northern hemisphere,
they're going clockwise.
We're going to explain that
later, in terms of how the
winds drive those currents.
But you can see that what
they're doing is bringing cold
water from the pole northward.
So once you know the sense of
the gyre, then the sense of
cold water or warm water
follows exactly.
So it's only a matter of what
direction are the gyres going.
And I'll explain that
when I get to the
ocean currents section.
Now I still haven't mentioned
seasons very much.
What can you do with just the
annual average values?
This is put together by a couple
of authors that have
tried to show the relationship
between climate and vegetation
based on an annual average
values only.
It's kind of useful, but I'm
going to argue it's not
complete, because it doesn't
include the seasonality.
But look what they've done.
They've made good progress.
So if you take the annual
average temperature plotted on
this axis, the annual average
precipitation plotted on the x
axis-- come along, and then they
have tried to illustrate
what kind of vegetation you
would get for each of those
climate zones.
Oh, notice the temperature scale
is reversed here, by the
way, It gets colder
to the right.
So tundra, taiga, temperate
deciduous rainforest, tropical
seasonal forest, all
these things.
So I enjoy looking at this
diagram, but then I get
confused because it doesn't
include the seasons in there.
And the seasons really
are needed to do
a good job of this.
So be aware of this.
The concept is called a biome.
The relationship between climate
and vegetation is
called the biome concept.
It's a very good concept, but
it doesn't work that well
unless you include the
seasons, which this
diagram does not.
So we are ready to start this
discussion of seasons, which
will spill over into next
time a little bit.
I find this to be a very useful
part of the course, a
very useful subject
to consider.
When I travel around the
world, I like to know--
I like to, first of all,
experience the fact that
traveling to a different part of
the world is going to give
me a different climate than
that that I grew up in.
And I want to understand--
every place I visit around the
world, I want to understand--
why is this climate different
and how do the seasons work
differently?
In kind of a silly
application--
I find it useful at the
beginning of the year, when
I'm coming back to school
seeing my colleagues.
Somebody will say, well, I've
just come back from Ghana, or
I've just come back from
Melbourne, Australia.
And I ask them, what month
were you there?
And they tell me and I say
something like, oh, that was
the dry season, or, oh,
that was the middle
of the rainy season.
Because once you get--
I want to give this to you
in the next few minutes--
once you get this basic picture
of how seasons work,
which is not too tough, you can
immediately know what's
going to happen as you travel to
various parts of the world
in various months of the year.
It's a pretty easy thing once
you get it categorized and
worked out.
So that's the understanding
we're striving for here.
How do the seasons work in
different parts of the world?
So just five bullet points
concerning seasons.
What causes the seasons on
Earth is the tilt of the
Earth's axis, 23 and a half
degrees currently.
So that when the-- and that
tilt is measured--
what's it measured from?
It's measured from the plane
of the ecliptic.
The plane of the ecliptic is
that plane in which the Earth
moves in its orbit.
That is our reference plane,
and relative to that plane,
the tilt is measured, the
tilt of the Earth
spinning on its axis.
For this reason, because it's a
tilt effect, during part of
the year the northern hemisphere
is tilted towards
the sun, and part of the Earth
is tilted away from the sun.
So the seasons are opposite
in the two hemispheres.
When it's winter in the north,
it's summer in the south, and
vice versa.
That's the primary effect of it
being a tilt effect, is you
get those opposite
seasonalities.
Now there is another effect.
The Earth's orbit is slightly
elliptical, which means for a
few months a year, we're a
little bit closer to the sun.
For a few months of the year
we're a little bit further
away from the sun.
That in and of itself would
cause a slight seasonality on
planet Earth.
It'd be warmer when we're closer
to the sun, a little
cooler when we're
further away.
(A) that's a pretty
small effect.
And (b) note that if that were
the dominant effect, that
would cause simultaneous seasons
in both hemispheres.
It'd be summer in both
hemispheres at the same time
and winter in both hemispheres
at the same time.
So this does not explain the
basic thing we know about
seasons, in that it's primarily
reversed in the two
hemispheres.
Any questions on that?
OK, now before I go any further,
I just want to
illustrate the basic idea here
about how the tilt of the
Earth does it.
I'm going to darken things off
just for a minute, and we'll
do a little globe
experiment here.
Can I set this right here?
So here's the Earth.
And the sun's over
there of course.
So as it goes around the sun,
the orientation of that tilt
remains fixed.
So as it goes around its orbit,
notice the orientation
of my pencil stays fixed.
That's important.
That arises from the
principle of
conservation of angular momentum.
Angular momentum is the quantity
that the Earth has
when it spins.
It's a vector quantity pointing
in a certain direction.
And that doesn't change.
You might have thought that as
the Earth goes around, maybe
it somehow does something
like this.
But no, no.
That orientation stays fixed
as it goes around.
So when it's on one side of the
sun, it's like this, and
when it's on the other side of
the sun, it's like this.
So remember, it's that constant
orientation of the
rotation axis that
is important in
understanding the seasons.
So let's start with an
orientation like this where
the tilt is oriented such that
it's across the direction of
the sun's rays.
Now, September 21st, just
two weeks ago--
I think it was on the day you
took your exam actually--
on that day, that was the
autumnal equinox.
That's when the Earth had
this orientation.
That tilt was, in a way
perpendicular to a line
between the sun and the Earth,
so that as the Earth spun on
its axis, it had equal
day and night
everywhere around the globe.
Now we are moving towards
December 21st, which will be
the winter solstice, and on that
day the orientation of
the Earth will be like that
relative to the sun.
Can you all see that?
So when it spins on its axis
again towards the east, the
southern hemisphere is receiving
a lot of heat, the
northern hemisphere is receiving
less, and the north
pole is getting none.
Notice this is completely in
shadow back here, because of
that direction.
Three months after that at the
spring equinox, it'll be like
this again.
And then on June 21st, the
summer solstice, that will be
the orientation of the Earth
relative to the sun.
And the north pole will have
sunlight 24 hours a day.
The south pole will have none.
A lot of radiation in the
northern hemisphere.
Less in the southern hemisphere,
because it's
tilted away.
And that is the cycle
we go through.
Remember, it all rises again,
because as the Earth goes
around in its orbit, that
orientation of the axis stays
fixed as it goes
around the sun.
That's the key ingredient
there.
Any questions on that?
You've probably had that in high
school, but there was a
survey done about 15 years ago
of graduating Harvard seniors.
And they were asked, what
makes the seasons.
And a shockingly small
percentage--
this was done, actually, as
they marched into their
graduation ceremony--
a shockingly small percentage
could explain that it was the
tilt of the Earth and
so on and so forth.
I don't want to that
to happen at Yale.
So you've got the message, and
spread it around, because how
can you live on this planet, I
ask you, how can you live on
this planet without
understanding that most basic
concept of how the
seasons work?
Questions there?
OK.
Now, a few other points.
What this does--
this shift of the radiation from
hemisphere to hemisphere
moves all of these belts and
zones along with them.
So we've talked about the ITCZ,
the belt of deserts to
the north to south of that,
the belts of storms to the
north and south of that.
Imagine that whole set of
systems shifting northwards in
the summertime for the northern
hemisphere, and
shifting southwards for the
summer in the southern
hemisphere.
That's probably the easiest way
to understand how climate
works on our planet, is to
envision that the general
circulation is driven by the
sun, and therefore if, because
of the tilt of the Earth's axis,
you move most of the
radiation into the northern
hemisphere, everything's going
to move with it.
If you move it into the
southern hemisphere,
everything's going to move
southward into it.
Now I will try to describe
that in various ways.
But you've got to understand
it well enough to sketch it
into your notes there.
So again this is just a picture
of the sun going
around the Earth--
no, the Earth going
around the sun.
Going back to the old geocentric
view of the
universe here briefly.
The Earth going around the sun,
thank you, and keeping
that orientation of that axis
fixed as it does so.
So if you're looking sideways at
the plane of the ecliptic,
the Earth here in grey is
moving in and out of the
board, going around in its orbit
staying in that ecliptic
plane and with a fixed
axis-- a fixed tilt
to its axis of rotation.
If you're on the Earth, in
kind of an Earth-fixed
coordinate system, it seems
to you like the
sun is actually moving.
In the summertime it seems
to be up high in the sky.
In the winter time it's
lower in the sky.
Of course that's not true.
It's just the fact that the axis
of the Earth is tilted.
For example, if you're at 41
degrees north latitude, as we
are here in New Haven, in the
summertime at the summer
solstice, the sun at noon would
be 23 and a half degrees
above the equator, which
means it's never
overhead here in New Haven.
But that solar zenith angle
is not very great.
You'd have to subtract 23 from
41 to get the solar zenith
angle at noon on the
21st of June.
On the 21st of December at noon,
the sun is down here.
We're still in New Haven.
The solar zenith angle would
then be 41 degrees plus 23.
What's that?
64 degrees.
The sun at noon is 64 degrees
below your zenith point.
And that has big influences,
of course, on the amount of
radiation received because
of that cosine factor.
It's the cosine of the zenith
angle that determines how much
radiation is being received per
unit area on the Earth.
And that's shown here.
So when the sun is above, you
get the full solar radiance.
When it's at some solar zenith
angle, it's the solar constant
times the cosine of the
solar zenith angle.
So the greater that off-zenith
angle is, the smaller is the
cosine and the less radiation
you receive.
So that cosine effect is another
important way to
understand how the
seasons work.
I did mention, however, this
other effect, this
non-circular aspect to
the Earth's orbit.
And it's shown a little bit
exaggerated in this diagram.
But at the present time,
the perihelion--
the day of the year when we're
closest to the sun--
is the third of January.
The aphelion--
when we're furthest away
from the sun-- is
the fourth of July.
And notice what that would
do, and in fact does do.
If this were the only effect,
it would make January a
slightly warmer month
than July.
So in the northern hemisphere,
when January is a cold month
because of the tilt of the
Earth, this would slightly
reduce the seasonality.
In the southern hemisphere, when
July is normally a cold
month, this effect
would strengthen
the seasonality slightly.
Now, this is a small effect,
but if you want to think
through what it's going to do,
with the current perihelion
being in January, it's going to
weaken northern hemisphere
seasons a little bit and
strengthen southern hemisphere
seasons a little bit.
We're going to revisit this when
we talk about the theory
of the ice ages, where it's
believed that changes in this
situation may have triggered
the coming and
going of the ice ages.
But at the current time I want
to emphasize that this is a
pretty small effect.
You can do a pretty good job of
understanding the seasons
on Earth without even knowing
about this effect.
You'd get it about 90% right.
So if you're at a particular
latitude and you go through
the months, how does the
insolation vary?
So what's shown here are four
different latitudes--
the equator, and then three
latitudes in the northern
hemisphere.
And what's plotted is the solar
insolation averaged over
a day in watts per
square meter.
Let's start with
the north pole.
Near the summer solstice, you're
getting about 500 watts
per square meter averaged
over a day.
It drops very rapidly as you go
later in the year, and at a
certain point it drops
altogether.
You get perpetual nighttime.
The sun never appears
in the sky.
As you go to lower latitudes--
remember the Arctic Circle,
because the tilt of the
Earth's axis is 23 and a half
degrees, the Arctic Circle is
66 and a half, right?
66 and a half.
So at 60 degrees, we're already
southward of the
Arctic Circle.
And so we don't quite get
darkness all day long, but the
amount of radiation received is
very small in the middle of
the winter.
And then when you get all the
way down to the equator, the
insolation received is almost
constant with the year.
Notice that for a few weeks,
averaged over a day, the north
pole actually receives more
than the equator does, but
it's a very brief thing.
And for the most part, if you
look at the total area under
the blue curve, which is the
equator, versus the area under
the yellow curve, which is the
pole, much more radiation is
received at the equator
than at the pole.
So this is a nice diagram for
remembering that it's the
amount of sunlight that's
received that's the key issue
here with the seasonality.
Questions here?
OK.
So back on this idea of the
belts moving seasonally,
quote, "following the sun." This
is an expression which is
just meant to help make it
easier to remember this.
They follow the sun.
That is, when there's more
sunlight hitting the northern
hemisphere, things move north.
South, south-- it works
the opposite way.
So here's a little cartoon
I put together.
So, for June, July, and August,
when the northern
hemisphere is tilted towards
the sun, first of all, the
polar front is very weak.
And that's because the amount
of radiation is almost the
same between the pole
and the equator.
So there's not very much
differential heating in the
southern-- sorry in the
summer hemisphere.
And in June, July, and August,
the northern hemisphere is the
summer hemisphere.
The ITCZ, which we've been
talking about being located at
the equator, actually shifts
northwards several degrees.
And the frontal storms in the
southern hemisphere become
very strong.
And the polar front moves a
little bit northward as well.
Six months later--
December, January, February--
when the southern hemisphere
is receiving most of the
radiation, the frontal storms in
the northern hemisphere are
very strong, because remember,
there's no radiation reaching
the north pole, and
a lot of radiation
reaching the equator.
So a lot of differential
heating.
In the southern hemisphere, the
ITCZ shifts southwards,
and you have weak frontal
storms in the southern
hemisphere, because there's very
little difference between
the solar insolation
here and there.
So that's the cartoon that's
going to guide us through the
next lecture, really.
We're out of time today.
But try to make some
sense of this.
Try to think through it.
And then I'm going to show you
to what extent this simple
idea is applicable to
the real world.
And that'll be next time.